good morning guys I just wanted to
quickly show you that everything is not
always smooth and easy here at home so
when you are going through the trials
and tribulations just go keep your eyes
fixed on God and do what you can and
just move through it so we have load
shading here right now power outages but
we have a generator there running
because of Ross and Liz thank you guys
so much
of course part of their part of the
family of Christian lifestyle men's
lifestyle and now we can still work and
because the power is out I got this
little guy here
so I'm making some breakfast I'm
actually so supposed to start working
but our Geezer you guys called it a hot
water heater just went as well so it's
not just the power it's the and they're
fixing it in there
so there's a lot going on here this is
the second hot water here actually last
month is another one I went
so in shorts I love you guys keep
fighting